[Music]
here at 8 news now we've been honoring
Valley seniors in tonight we want to
take a minute to congratulate our 8 News
Now family senior these grads are
related to someone here at the station
so let's get started with a big
congratulations there is - Connor Foley
yay Connor Connor son of Tim and Terrie
Foley graduated today from Faith
Lutheran High School awesome Connor and
we know this girl graduating from Faith
Lutheran as well Ethan David Ben oh my
gosh she was just a little tight
now he's like 6 foot 7 your mom family
super proud of you congrats Ethan also
congratulations to Lorenzo Jackson
brother originally a Jackson he's headed
to LSU in the fall yay Lorenzo Merle
Michelle Dietrich nieces are employed
Karen Dietrich graduating from Foothill
High School a year early way to go
Laurel and Congrats to Shelby Carvalho
graduating from Liberty High School
heading to Binghamton grandma Deb Rhea
didn't very proud of you shall be
congratulations my dear this is Belle
niece and goddaughter of host JC
Fernandez right Belle graduating from
Quakertown Community High School in
Pennsylvania and congratulations to
jaylen Lopez niece of photojournalist
robando Navarro
all right Jalen way to go Nathaniel
diamond son of Sharon and Kevin Garnett
graduating from Northern Arizona
University Congrats Nathaniel all grown
up Wow
I think Ethan I've known since he's
about six years old yeah that is crazy
way taller than me